Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host, Rawkode.
Today,
I don't even know what episode number we
are on, but we are continuing our exploration
of running Laravel
in a production fashion on Kubernetes.
Last week, I was joined by Alex and
Kieran, and we had a little bit of
trouble or problems getting a Laravel metaware to
expose or export Prometheus metrics to be scraped
to allow us to horizontally scale.
Fortunately,
our friend
Leo is here to help us today. Who
has? And, funnel, I don't know how sad
it is this time it was, but you
actually had written this exact bit of middleware
that we needed
just prior to that episode. Is that right?
Yes. So I was talking to you, I
think, like, the day before or something, and
I was looking into Prometheus.
And so I wrote that, and then I
completely missed the episode. And I was rewatching
it after, and, you know, as soon as
I was like, alright. I I just wrote
this yesterday. It would have been real good
to watch this live and just, you know,
link to link to the package.
Yeah. That would have been invaluable, I think,
that day. We we tried two different packages,
Alex and I, and just
really just didn't get anything to work.
Yeah.
Nothing work. We're parkour net, and nothing worked
at the end of last episode.
But
So every taste Yeah. Different stories, though.
Yeah. No pressure, Leo. Alright.
Okay. Forget my manners. Let's do a quick
introduction. So we'll start with you, Alex. We'll
move over to Leo, and then we'll get
started again.
Cool. Yeah. I'm Alex. I'm a PHP Laravel
developer that doubles a bit in Kubernetes and
then getting a bit closer towards dealing with
that more production, hence, doing these streams with
David.
Yeah. And I'm Leo. I'm the CTO at
Jobberle. We build recruitment software. We're a very
small team, so I do pretty much all
of the DevOps side of things, which is
why I've been doing the monitoring and Kubernetes
things here, which is why I'm now here
to hopefully not break things.
Fingers
crossed.
Alright.
I guess what we should just do is
get the screen shared,
quickly run over in under three minutes where
we are again, and then just let's try
and get your library imported running,
and then we'll tackle the scalability side with
Kubernetes.
All right.
Let's see.
So this is the repository,
github.com/alexpowers/laravel-example-project.
I don't think I even pushed last week's
failure to it, but we'll do that after
today when it works. I
have Versus Code. Leo has kindly joined me.
Good. Because you'll be fixing everything that I
do.
And we have a make file,
which has our build targets,
which I did this time build ahead.
So we do have two container images. We
can deploy this to Kubernetes. So let's just
do that first, confirm that it works, then
integrate Leo's library.
So if we open our Kubernetes directory,
I think we can probably just reapply all
of this. I don't think if we yeah.
We did add some Prometheus stuff that I
am gonna nuke.
And we'll do that clean. Do we not
want to keep any of the Prometheus stuff?
No. Because
the service monitor's weren't working last week, and
it looks like it's just a bug in
the the
operator that we were using.
So I have gone ahead and deployed my
own
Prometheus to the cluster and we're just gonna
configure it the old fashioned way. We're not
gonna use the service monitors on the operator
this time. So
that is just, I'm more familiar with it
this way. I don't wanna have to try
and fix the bug in an open source
project in our stream and I don't have
time before prior. So,
let's apply our operations
Kubernetes directory,
and this should get our application up and
running in just about ten or twenty seconds.
So we'll give that a few moments,
confirm that it works. I guess what we
can do just now is start to pull
in your library, Neil.
Yes. You can start pulling it in, but
that will not work. So what you will
have to do is actually install the APCU
extension in PHP.
So that is a user level cache,
which the Prometheus the underlying Prometheus library uses
that instead of Redis.
That is a choice I made in the
library. So instead of Redis,
it uses the APC
user cache,
which allows you to get kind of an
in memory store
to store between requests, which is how it's
storing the
request count and stuff like that. Alright. I'm
I'm so glad I built all that stuff
beforehand.
Yes.
But it is it should be two lines
in the Dockerfile, so I think we're good.
Yeah. But I oh, actually, we don't have
a working cache if I remember right from
last time anyway. Yeah. Okay. So No. The
stuff resolved. Yeah. We will fix the cache
now then. Right? So we can just do
this. We'll see if this builds. Normally, there's
a small
why is that copying it to such a
random place actually? Oh, that's just where we
copy everything. Okay. No worries because we're using
the Rector.
That's where I'm okay at this stuff. Okay.
So we have the composer dot JSON. We're
gonna do the composer install.
Sometimes, I think Laravel does fail with that
because of the
something, but let's just see what happens.
Alright.
Can I just do run
Docker PHP install
a p c go?
I am not sure if it'll work with
PHP
install.
I've used
peckle, so PHP extension
library manager, whatever it's called.
We can try it with PHPX install.
It may or may not work. Otherwise, there
is a simple way to do it, which
will just be two lines instead of one.
Well, why don't we just do a entry
point bash, jump inside this?
Surprised that our image doesn't narrow because I've
built the image. Yeah. It does. Yeah. It's
just this low. And this is all paints.
We wanna run ash.
Okay. So Docker
extension
install as a p c u on list.
No.
Okay. So we're doing the peckle approach.
Yes.
And you're saying the command is PECL install
a p c u?
Yep. That's all. And then what you wanna
put in the Docker file is also
Docker PHP
EXT enable a p c u.
Alright. Well, we had our first nag installing
that.
Of course, we did.
You need to install auto comps, I guess.
So Yeah. We'll need to build
There is.
Yes.
There is actually, if memory serves, a dollar
PHPIs
underscore depths that you can use in the
build step,
which has all the PHPIs dependencies.
So it's an environment variable that you can
use with the Alpine images.
Okay. So you're saying if I run the
peckle install again, but with an environment variable?
No. Sorry. So it's it's
just a list of packages that you pass
to APK. Alright. Gotcha. Okay. So
PHPIs depths.
Yeah. Looks good. Third from the bottom.
Yes.
Alright. How did I not see that? Okay.
So it's just APK ad PHPIs deps.
Yeah. I don't know why this is three
ads, but whatever.
I'm gonna say that It was because I
I did them one at a time, I
didn't wanna have to redo the old ones
which you've already done. Yeah. Presumably, the build
cache. Right?
Yeah. I will need an update. If we
have to rebuild anyway, then I guess. Yeah.
Okay.
So we want to use Leo's library. We
need EPC here. We're using that instead of
an external Redis. I've added the PHPIs depth.
This should
allow me now to run a pickle
install
EPCU.
And let's just confirm. Like, I'll run this
You need to delete the line nine as
well because you've got the pipeline in there
still. I will just do that. There we
go. Line six. Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.
Echo.
And we expect this to work. Hopefully, it's
nice and quick, and then we can rebuild
our images.
I don't really want a question.
I wonder if that's gonna block my build.
It will not because it will default when
it's non interactive.
Good.
That's what I like to hear.
I know this because this code runs in
production for me, so
it it should work.
And we do use 7.4 FPM Alpine
as the base. You're you're already throwing all
of your excuses out the window for when
this doesn't work. You need to
need to save some of these.
Okay. I am fully confident.
There's no help anyway. So I'm just gonna
go with that. And then you said we
wanted to run a Docker PHP extension enabled
APC.
Yeah. Yep. And that is what adds it
to the PHP in the file.
Okay. So we need one more command.
Docker PHP
extension enabled
APC.
Alright. So this modifies our base image. This
should mean that anything we build subsequently down
will have it.
We have moved this composer dot up. This
this composer is all up to try
and keep our cache here, but we are
about to make a change to composer dot
JSON. So why don't we do that first
so that we don't have to do two
builds?
Yep. So I'll let Leo do a little
bit of typing.
You wanna show us how to install your
library?
Yes. I need to actually remember what it's
called. There we go.
The the easy way to do it is
just going straight into the documentation and and
following that. You want me to build up
the docs for your library? Where is it,
by the way? We should tell people. So
github.com.
Yes. It's github.com/jovila/laravelcloudnativeutilities.
It also has a bit of defaults for,
like, logging configuration.
I kinda just tossed everything into one place.
Alright.
So But I have added it now,
so that should be good to go. This
is the release I just tagged a moment
ago with support.
So
that shouldn't break anything else.
Shouldn't is my favorite word on the show.
Telling you now. Okay.
Let's try and build this then. So we've
got two main targets. I'm only gonna build
FPM.
We don't need to worry about NGINX again.
Don't really just wanna check that Docker file.
I wanna move artisan up because I know
there's weird behavior if that doesn't exist. We
had that on a previous episode, but I
think we'll Yeah. Save us out the rest.
You can get around the artisan problem if
if you wanna do that as well.
I mean, I'll just talk through it because
we're waiting for the build anyway. Yeah. The
way you do that is to run dash
dash no order loader, which will prevent running
the scripts,
and then you run dump order load after
copying in the app files.
That way, we'll be able to run all
the scripts and order loader and stuff, and
it doesn't need artisan ahead of time.
Yeah. There was another weird issue, though, with
Yeah. Laravel mix On the assets. Yeah. Requires
yeah. The JavaScript's
compiling stuff for webpack requires artisan as a
file to exist.
It uses that to find out the Laravel
root,
which
took a long time for us to find
on the stream.
But yeah.
Alright. Well, well, hopefully, as image builds, so
okay. If I remember right from last week,
it's the random ninety ninety seconds mark, so
it's not not too bad.
And then we should be in a position
where we can just start instrumenting.
Is that is that all auto instrumenting then,
this this library?
Yes. So there is a configuration file for
it.
So, yeah, the installation docs do have there
is a command you can run to publish
a config file.
By default, it's gonna expose a slash metrics
endpoint
that
I think it has quite sensible buckets of
0.1,
zero point two, point three, four, five,
point seven five one two and five seconds
or something like that. There's a lot of
buckets. There's, 10 of them or something.
Alright. Well, that should give us a little
flexibility then when it comes to adding our
horizontal pod autoscaler. So I I did also
yeah. Sorry. I I did add
just couple days ago the support for changing
that in the config. So if you do
wanna change the buckets,
you can publish that configuration file as well.
Well, you know I'm gonna test that now.
Yes. Of course. I have not tested it,
but that that'll be interesting. We'll see what
happens. I'm curious. Like, you're using this in
production at at Jobula. Right? So are you
using a horizontal pod autoscaler in your Kubernetes
setup at the moment?
We are not using it at the moment.
Largely, we have a very stable load,
and we are I mean, we we survive
fine on honestly, like, one pod one replica,
maybe two.
We don't really need to scale up a
lot.
We do have got a lot of resources
for each pod. Yep.
So it's running quite fine.
Also, I did write this library, like, last
week. So,
you know, I I just have not had
time to do it. But I'm making up
the excuse that, you know, we don't need
it. Are you again? You just got to
get a little done early.
So at the moment, are you basically using
it in production just to gather the metrics
rather than to make use of the metrics?
Yes.
Literally gathering them because we barely have a
functioning Grafana setup as well.
I probably shouldn't be saying these kind of
things on the stream if when I try
to,
like, work with me.
No. We have a we have a beautiful
environment.
That doesn't look good.
The requirements could not be resolved.
It looks like you require a certain guzzle
installation
in one of your currencies.
Yeah. I don't yes.
Because we have requested 70.1,
and they're saying 6
Yes. So that's requested by the Prometheus
client library.
Alright. If in doubt, six dot star, why
not? Is that how you do it? See,
I was trying to remember, but it's you
know, I haven't read it right You can
just do greater than six point o. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah.
I don't know if does greater than work
with the asterisks?
I'm not sure.
Also, it it is the up caret yep.
All good. Alright.
But I should start from our composer step
anyways. So let's see. Yeah. That's true. Yeah.
No. It does not like that. Okay. You
can't do it as chevron and the star.
Just do chevron Zero.
Yeah.
We're professionals. We know what we're doing.
I'm not. I'm relying on user.
There we go. It's happy. Right. That looks
better.
And I'm pretty sure there was nothing in
my code that was using Guzzle at all,
so nothing else should break.
There's the artisan issue. Okay. You need to
copy Bootstrap.
It might be worth just putting the computer
installed back where it was. Yeah. Let's just
do everything. I don't wanna fight with that.
I don't wanna fight with that today. I
fought with that in the past. I don't
have it. I don't remember the solution at
the top of my head. We'll deal with
that later.
Yeah.
I think it's probably what Leo said before.
Make it so it doesn't do any of
the scripts afterwards, and then when them yourself
have to copy the rest of the files.
Yeah. Let's just get this deployed. I wanna
see this metrics endpoint work. I wanna configure
the buckets, and then we'll start scaling.
Oh, I already did the dump porta load
after the fact as well. It's interesting.
Oh, well.
Okay. We have our images.
Now we're just building the same tag. So
that means if I do get pods, all
I really need to do here is delete
our
Laravel pod
here. And we're only running one.
This will trigger it to use the new
image. I'm gonna port forward at metrics.
In fact, we've not we've only added it
to composite dot JSON. Is there any other
steps, Leo?
No. That should be it, or
it should do something.
I I guess we'll find out if it
does. Right? I mean, I'll need to add
it to, like, some configuration
or No. Laravel has auto discovery.
That's what was mentioned last stream when we
had to start finding which file to add
the references
to when somebody was saying about auto discovery.
That's one of the things that came in
like Okay. So we have our posts. We
have our home page. Do we have metrics?
That's the moment of truth.
We do. No. We we did hard code
some metrics last week, though. Have you removed
the hard coded ones?
Because I think we put our own No.
This the hard coded one. Yeah. So what
happens is the library registers its own route.
But if you register the same route afterwards,
then your route will take precedence.
Yeah. Which is going to roots and it'll
be in web. Web. Web dot PHP.
Oh, yeah. That's my Yeah. Just delete that.
Yeah.
Right.
I was like, oh, it works. My library
works.
Everything is fine.
Does work. I had we're not confirmed it
yet. Don't worry. It's coming.
Alright. Quick rebuild then. Yeah. And this is
where we need to do some more work
on the composer on the Dockerfile.
Because we haven't changed any of our dependencies.
But because we are gonna change this time
and time again today. So Yeah. We're only
gonna really change app and routes. Right?
Yes.
I was like, maybe we can get away
with that.
Mhmm. Probably case.
Oh, no. We're dot
probably We're gonna configure the
the buckets, and I'm assuming that'll be in
config. So why don't we try it with
these two? Just and if it doesn't work,
we'll just have to deal with the rebuild
every time, I think. So let's check out
the one more. And while that does the
I'm gonna color pod.
We'll check this metrics endpoint.
So that's deleting.
We can do a port forward.
I really should have checked the name.
Oh, that failed again. So I I think
we're just gonna have to deal with the
thing.
I don't think it worked.
It worked.
I saw that looking at the store. He
was worried.
I I told you. I I had full
confidence in my code here. I think the
challenge was maybe the patient on the first
load,
but I think we're good. Okay.
So that worked. We have metrics.
Let's jump back over here and we're yeah.
We just have to unfortunately deal with that.
So let's try not to make too many
changes on the PHP side. And if we
do need to make some, we should probably
just make them know and kick off that
rebuild. Yeah. But we do some of the
you want, we
because we're only dealing with the metrics now,
I suppose we could also just do the
no auto loader step right away
because we're not dealing with any issues related
to resources
probably.
At least there's no build step related to
mix.
So if you just do dash dash no
auto loader,
you can have it right after the composer
JSON copy.
Yeah. That will help us. Yeah.
I just wanna make sure we don't spend
too much time phasing it this.
Yes.
I'm
hoping this should be quicker, though.
Alright. It looks like it's maybe getting a
bit further than that.
Is that happy? Is that our last ever
compulsory install?
Oh. There we go. Nice. I think it's
very optimistic to call it your last composer
install.
Ever.
And done. Okay.
I'm really happy with that. So
what do we need to do now?
Well,
we wanna start
scraping
the
metrics.
Let me grab Yes. We need to get
a data into Prometheus, I guess, aren't we?
Yes.
Now the old school way of doing this
is to modify the deployment.
Oh, we're not using like a d anymore.
I don't know. I just prefer that approach.
Fine.
These are the three annotations that tell Prometheus
to scrape within Kubernetes.
I think we're running on port 80, so
we'll just leave that open.
Is that the port inside of the container?
It is. Yes. Yeah. Port a t. Yeah.
So we just tell previous that we want
to scrape by saying this to a string
through. We tell the endpoint to scrape in
the port number.
Most of these are at the fact. I'm
pretty sure a t and slash metrics are
the defaults and I could remove them, but
I'm not going to.
Just trust me. That that's always worked out
well.
We're gonna reapply our Kubernetes manifest.
So
we're gonna get pods. There's there's still stuff
in there about PON.
Are they still needed? Because they were put
there last week for
our attempts.
Sorry. Can you say that again? What's in
here? Go to the top.
Line fourteen nineteen.
Are those still necessary? Because we put those
in last week. No. That was when we
were trying to target the service monitor and
it was that bug. Yep. Okay.
We can reapply and actually oh,
you can't change them. So they're immutable.
It's deploy Laravel.
Let's just make it and then reapply with
it.
Alright. Let's see where we are.
So
give that one more second. Okay. It's running.
I wanna make sure we have some metrics
that we can scrape with
from me, so I'm just gonna put forward
one one more time. At least for now,
one more time
at the metrics endpoint.
Do you need to hit a different URL
to get metrics first? Yeah. I think that's
the issue.
There you go. You
might be correct? Yeah.
Yes. So there's just no metrics upfront. That's
all it is. No no nothing's came through
and hit.
Not a big deal, but we do have
some stuff here. So what we really wanna
check now is that if I browse to
Prometheus, one, we should see that there's a
target that wants to be scraped. Two, we
should see some metrics
and three,
maybe that'll all work. So
I'm not gonna
port forward to that anymore. Instead,
we're port forward to our Prometheus server, which
runs on port nineteen ninety.
Local host
1990.
We have our Prometheus UI.
Now if we come into target
oh, come on.
Oh, there we go. Is it there? I
saw some proof eighty eighty on there.
But we're targeting 80. Right?
Oh, shit. Yeah. Yeah.
That's
what is going on there?
Yeah. That's a Kubernetes service.
This is where my expertise ends because I
set this up with a service monitor, and
I was all happy.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So this this is on
David to figure out.
There's another tab on the status called service
discovery. Would that that have any met bearing
on it or not?
Because I'd assume that we'd be listed as
a service on there. Right?
Maybe it's just not picked it up yet,
to be fair.
Looks like we have anything here. No.
Chrome page.
Yeah. So we should be showing up here
based on those annotations. So let's quickly check
we haven't I haven't missed anything up.
So
we got a question that I'll throw to
Leo.
William asks,
should normal setup health checks generate some initial
metrics? So, yeah, the probes if we had
probes on our
deployment,
I can't remember if we do, those should
probably populate the first source.
First They would.
Yeah. They would. And I think a question
here as well is,
would you really want that? Right now, the
way the library works is it excludes
all requests that hit the slash metrics route,
but nothing else.
So it might make sense to
add support for excluded routes.
I'd imagine you might not want the health
check
timings necessarily.
I don't know if you want that in
your metrics or not.
Okay. Good question.
I don't have any labels here.
Did I put them in the wrong place?
Why is my old tab not working? There
we go.
Yes.
Yep. You did.
It should be on the template.
Yes.
It's meant to have to one more. Yeah.
Okay.
Right.
I I'm sure everything will work now.
God. Whatever This is your first stream, I
guess, then, is it?
It's the first stream where I'm participating.
It's the first time I
collection Everything has worked so far aside from
not being able to build the container and
a few other things. Except for my stuff,
you mean. Thanks for that. Okay. So that's
now running.
All good.
Okay. So we'll need to hit a few
routes again to get some data back on
it, won't we? So you'll need to port
forward it again.
That is correct.
Port forward
this part here.
There's
a there's something called kubed forward. Terminating.
Alright. There is a
project called forward that actually exposes all of
your services locally. I really should just start
running that for these streams, but
we'll make do it for today.
Alright. So let's have post,
home page,
and then we should see some nice metrics
in here.
Perfect.
What I wanna see in the targets now
is our Laravel application.
No. We do need to maybe
wait the scrape interval.
How long what is the interval? I I
believe I have it set to ten seconds.
Okay.
If that doesn't work, I'll gently nudge Prometheus
and we'll see what happens.
But we are in the same namespace.
Alright. I know I'm getting a bit tab
crazy now, but
let's see.
Everything is in default.
So I would expect the previous to be
scraping our Laravel application just now, unless I've
got
anything
wrong.
I see the labels are on the pod.
I have annotation. Sorry.
Yeah. Looks alright.
When did start
hating me?
Alright. What have I got wrong? Let's nudge
Prometheus.
So I get pods.
Delete pods.
Should be restarting
now.
Yep.
We can forward.
You spelled forward wrong.
Thank you.
I saw something there slash metrics with no
port on it,
which would imply,
I guess, No.
It's monitoring itself. So
Oh, is that yourself? Oh, okay. Yeah. Our
stuff is not showing up.
Fabulous.
Is it definitely on the same namespace?
They are on the same namespace. Yes. They
are.
Do you need to change anything on Prometheus'
side to tell it what
labels to look for?
No.
No. But we do have buckets.
So
this is my application and these match what
we have here.
So if I don't retest that just quickly,
root equals slash post.
Did I get that wrong?
There's no slash on it. Oh, it's yeah.
Just post.
Okay. We are getting our metrics.
It's obviously just heading in our target somewhere,
and I'm scrolling past there.
Oh, no. It's there. It's there. Yeah. Yeah.
That's what I was on about. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not getting insane. It's all good.
Alright.
Good.
Everything is working. We have our metrics.
We can, in theory, apply
an HPA
and scale this based on
the response time rate. And one of the
things that I think is really important with
pod auto scaling, You know, we talked about
this a little bit last week, but scaling
on
CPU utilization or memory doesn't
give you any indication of what an experience
your end user or customers are getting. Always
always better to scale
on
the real response time. Like, I'm assuming, Leo,
do you have any SLAs or an ideal
response time that you expect your customers to
get a response from?
So we we don't enforce any SLAs,
but we are trying to now to keep
a 95 p of two hundred milliseconds on
the API. I would like to have that
down to one fifty ideally.
And I would I would agree that especially
with PHP applications, it's even more important that
you don't scale
particularly on memory.
Because if you want to optimize your setup,
you wanna be running with a static number
of FPM processes. So you're basically gonna have
static memory consumption.
Yep.
Alright. And do you wanna tell us what
about p 95 is?
Yes. So the
ninety fifth percentile,
so 95%
of the request going in under that
amount of time, so two hundred milliseconds
for 95%
of the requests.
Exactly.
Alright.
Now
before we go throwing the HP on this
then, why don't we run siege against this
post endpoint? Like, right now, we can see
that our buckets are
or nothing is responding in under five hundred
milliseconds. So,
really, we're gonna start to see hopefully plus
five seconds plus infinity buckets really start to
fill up over the
zero and a half to 0.75.
But why don't we try and emulate this
in a way that maybe is real world
day?
Is that a word that is today?
So
we just see each last time. Right? And
we just we don't really tune
any parameters.
Is there a way we can just throw
change.
Sorry. Go on.
That's alright.
How can I just I I just wanna
send a couple of hundred requests to this?
I don't wanna overwhelm the system. I don't
wanna I just wanna see a few buckets
fill up with some data. Is there a
flag?
There's a You can dash c.
Right? Dash c is concurrency. Dash t is
how long it should run for. I don't
know if you can set the specific number
of requests. I'm not sure about that one.
Well, I mean, I don't make control c
in that, I guess. So I know you
can in Apache benchmarks.
How big are reps?
Reps sounds usually. Dash r.
Well, I'm gonna add dash p, so I
wanna print stuff. Concurrent
is only 10. I'm okay with that. Let's
just do a concurrency one so we can
control
what's happening.
Let's
do
reps of
let's just do 1,000 request.
That's gonna take, like, a thousand seconds. I
can currently see one. Let's just do 10
here. 20 requests for now.
Time, I don't think we need to worry
about delay. I don't think we need to
worry about I don't think we need to
worry about anything else listed here. We happy
with that?
Mhmm.
Alright.
Oh, the p is actually printing at HTML.
I I just wanted a summary of the
request. I don't know I actually want to
output. You get you get the summary of
the request once you cancel it off normally.
I I was hoping I'd get a running
count or something. Yeah. Make it a bit
more visual.
That's not a big deal. Okay. Cool.
How big is your history on your terminal?
Your scroll history?
And because all the oh, okay. Right. Right
now. But I'm not fast. We're we're not
gonna do another print. And now I'm gonna
do this one more time on the correct
endpoint.
But what's cool there is we can actually
see a request. We actually have a a
spread, a pretty even distributional spread to be
fair, even at a hundred requests. So I
don't think
triggering a scale is gonna be too difficult.
I'm actually really surprised at the currency of
one sending 20.
That's not right because we've got, like,
we've got a lot of requests here.
Does it send more than 20
or does your code not work, Leo?
My code works perfectly.
I it's a good question. I'm a little
concerned about 21
showing up.
Exactly the same. We either have it's
either a very even distribution
Or a bug. Or maybe problem.
We only have bugs in here. So we
have 20 transactions,
all responded correctly,
and
do we have a average time response time
of roughly
we think that's three hundred milliseconds.
Yeah.
Oh,
I think there is a bug. Showing
yes. So if they're
because there's 20 requests. Right? And we have
21 on everything. Excellent.
I I knew something would happen.
It's not a big deal for today. We
can still we All we really wanna do
is inflate these metrics anyway
and we can still do our testing. But
yeah, it looks like the library
maybe has a wee bug in it.
Alright. Yeah. That's Here's the total request down
here. We got 21 on each end point.
Yeah. And a few 20 one's gonna spread
across there. Weird bug.
But alright.
I thought I actually think the 13 requests
that went onto into here are probably correct.
Not sure what the other ones are. Maybe
it's just a I'm
I'm confused about it. I am relying
on the Prometheus PHP library, so I'm a
little concerned about that.
Uh-huh. See how he just delegated that bug
channel I'm not sure I'm not sure if
I am just misunderstanding how to use the
library. That is quite likely.
But you know what? I don't right now,
I'm just happy we have a metrics standpoint
that is somewhat working, and we can work
with today. So We actually managed to install
it this week, which is a progress over
the two that you tried last week. So
Alright.
So you'll work on that.
I'm gonna work on the service monitor bug
over the next week or two, but we
can get away with that right now by
using the old school annotation approach.
So we have metrics.
Now, if we want to
be able to scale based on these. So
I'm just gonna recap a few things from
last week that I think maybe makes sense.
Let's pull this down.
So we're running Kubernetes.
We installed a metrics server. If you didn't
see that, go watch last week's episode. The
metrics server is what allows us to actually
get metrics out of Kubernetes.
It gave us resource utilization metrics on CPU
and memory. If you want to augment that,
you have to use
a metrics adapter.
And we don't have that installed yet. That's
what we have to do
now.
We did that last week?
Yeah. I think so.
Because we put the metrics server on there,
and then we tried to get data into
it from Prometheus, and that's where we failed.
Alright.
Okay.
So this should just be a case
of installing the helm chart version of the
Prometheus adapter.
I don't think I need to tweak the
values in any way, but we'll
see what happens.
The Prometheus adapter gets installed to the cluster.
Actually it gets encapsulated with the metric server
and provides extra endpoints so that we can
query the metric server for the custom metrics
from Prometheus. I know it's a really weird
setup,
but you kind of get used to it.
In fact, we can just
see if we have any custom metrics available
here.
Might not be available yet though.
Yeah. Not quite ready yet. So give it
a few more seconds.
While we wait for this, I can also
confirm I am
now 97%
certain that I am just incompetent at using
this
latest library,
misunderstanding
how you think the bucket is. How to
report buckets.
So I I think that will be an
improvement that I will be making
after the stream.
Alright. You don't wanna fix it right now?
I'll I'll try, but but not make any
promises. No. I'm make us spend too much
time on pulling in version zero point one
point five, one point six, seven
until it's fixed.
Alright. Well,
it looks like we're
okay
now.
Our pod is no longer pending any probes.
We actually get a response from custom metrics
here.
There is this really long man
that will allow us to create a pod
metrics from Prometheus. We'll see if it works.
So
I thought I should just share the link
that I'm getting this from as well. This
was a stream I did a month ago
with my friend Guy,
who is the chair of SIG Auto Scaling
or co chair of SIG Auto Scaling Kubernetes.
And this is that auto scaling example workshop
that we did live on the stream
and we're reusing most of these components.
And the docs says this command, which allows
us to actually query. So I just need
to tweak this. Right? So namespace default is
fine. I'll pause, and we're looking for h
two p request per second, which I believe
we don't quite have. Let's copy total.
Also, I can confirm
I can now tell you exactly how the
library works. I just looked at the code,
and it is kind of correct, actually. You
should be getting 21 in all of them
because 0.5
is
a longer duration than 0.3,
and that's why you're seeing 13 at the
lower numbers.
I wouldn't bucket them that way.
No. But as in that is the way
the library buckets them, so that's why they
appear that way.
Alright.
I mean, I think that's a bug, but
it's not a big deal.
Alright. We'll label selected match.
Oh, yeah. Okay. So we want
app.
What was the syntax there? Equal.
They had a percent three d, I think.
Did it? I think it was, like, a
the entity first slash, I think.
Yeah. I've got it over here.
Interesting.
The server could not find the metric HTTP
request total.
HTTP request
total
for pods.
Alright. We'll move on for now. Hopefully, it's
not a problem.
It could be,
of course, there's always something is that maybe
I do need to point this towards our
Prometheus.
Let's see. Do we have a service?
We do.
In fact, let's just pull up that chart.
Let's take a quick look rather than speculate.
So
it is the Prometheus
adapter.
Here.
In fact, it was the Prometheus community.
This is the chart we installed.
We can go to the repository.
Nope. This one.
Once it's in place. Okay.
And do we have the values
that we can tweak?
Where's the chart?
Why?
It's just manifest.
That's the actual code for the adapter and
not the helm chart.
Maybe it was this first one. This deprecated
one. Maybe it still just lives in there.
Let me face adapter.
Okay. Oh, there we go. That's it.
That was a long way about to get
there, wasn't it? Anyway,
now we can go into the charts.
We installed the adapter.
We wanna look at the values fail and
just see if there's any configuration that tells
us where our Prometheus live. So we can
see here,
it actually does expect there to be a
Prometheus service,
which I do not have.
So we can redeploy it with a small
tweak to this
and it should should
exit.
So let's
create a quick
Prometheus
adapter
values.
Yml.
I know I should probably move that into
our ops directory, build it there.
And ours is called
server.
That's right. Yeah? Are you happy with that?
Yep.
Yeah. Prometheus server.
Oh, port 80, the service.
Why
port 80? Because you were forwarding port ninety
ninety before. Yeah. That's a hard port, but
this service is mapping it to port 80.
So
Oh, okay. Right. Okay. So I'm gonna reinstall
this using a values file,
which is there.
Oh, and we already installed it. Upgrade.
Okay.
Let's wait for that one to get healthy.
I guess we'll wait a bit longer then.
A lot of waiting
in Kubernetes.
I was gonna say this is really the
Kubernetes experience.
Yeah. It is definitely.
Now there
we go. Okay.
So we had
curl request that we
No, we had a kubectl raw request that
we fired away. First one was just to
hit this and that's looking a lot better
actually.
Let's see if we get our request total.
No.
I'm gonna ask if it's working, though.
Yeah. Is this like so definitely up slash
and not just Laravel example project?
That's okay. Because the selected that we the
label we put on the actual deployment doesn't
have app slasher, I think. The label itself
is app. Right?
Let's
just work it out. Let's just stay up
the old scale. I'll see what happens.
I mean, we can always take a look
at like, we see quite a lot coming
back from here.
That wasn't coming back last time. So I'm
confident that it's speaking to Prometheus.
Now, when we use the raw URL,
we can extend that to actually Google
deeper into it. And that's just supposed to
actually proxy a request on to Prometheus to
give us a response.
That's HTTP request. Total is a metric name
passing in the selector
of app Laravel.
I mean, I would expect that to work,
but I'm not gonna let it hold me
up just now. So why don't we create
our HPA?
We're the same page? That all makes sense.
I don't wanna
jump ahead here.
I think it makes sense. Well,
we'll come back to that
if it doesn't matter.
Okay. So
here is our standard HPA.
Now what do we need to tweak here?
We'll
just keep continue calling this Laravel example.
We have to tell it what target. We
are targeting an employment.
Ours is called Laravel
example project,
I think.
Mhmm.
Yep.
We're gonna go from one to 10 depending
on how we need to scale.
Metrics are gonna come from pods and then
our metric name. So we can copy this.
I mean, we can do it from I'm
not put forwarding anymore so we can't. But
let's copy it from
just because there's a bit of unknown around
how these function, I'll use request total and
we'll just scale
depending on our aggregate account of the number
of requests because that's a really smart idea.
And what we wanna say is that oh,
no. It's not really gonna work because of
the target value. Alright. Let's
let's go with the So what's
what's the time frame on the request total?
Is that always increasing,
or does it reset back to zero, like,
daily, hourly? Like, what's the deal on that?
When the pod is restarted because we're using
APC here, then the total will be reset
with it.
Right. Okay. So That total will actually reset.
Well, yeah. We're actually gonna be collecting that
from all of the pods. They're all gonna
have different values.
So
be a little interesting,
but we should get an aggregate We only
have of it. We do only have one
just now. Yes.
K.
Let's just see what happens. We'll set it
to
we expect it to be
five.
We'll tweak it as we we play.
Okay.
Let's reapply all of our Kubernetes resources. We
should see that we have a created HPA.
We can create this
and we can describe
it.
HPA
Laravel.
I
think our selector
is maybe wrong.
It seems to think we have nothing. What
did I get wrong?
Employment.
Laravel.
Is it worth checking our deployment to see
what the label is on that?
Yeah.
Yeah. It does match up.
I'm looking at it and It's it's right.
It it should work.
Well, that's the story of my life with
this Laravel stuff to be fair.
Alright.
Let's see.
Unable to fetch the metrics in the custom
metrics API, the server. Okay. So
it's trying to request these metrics.
Okay. So it's not yeah. That makes sense.
So why is it unable to get those
metrics?
We were unable to get them too
with
Rawk. That's not
good.
Maybe we just got something wrong.
But we can always clear the big messy
one. Type it to jq and try and
understand what we're getting back.
I think we're gonna need to go through
less.
And
then I lose my colors. That's annoying. Okay.
So
not interesting.
Not interesting. I wonder if I should just
filter it on
Laravel.
Oh, we're not getting any metrics here.
So I think that's a problem.
Let's just quickly do dash a
pod.
Because they were coming into Prometheus.
Right?
Well, let's just double check that's still working.
That's for sure.
Port forward
Prometheus
server.
Yeah. It's still the same, which means I
should be able to refresh this.
And we come to graph,
then we can do HTTP request
total.
And we have our 21 requests.
If we take a look at our buckets
over
twenty minutes,
graph.
Oh, I guess we don't have enough data.
But we do we do have a value.
Yes.
This
here,
we got app equals Laravel example project. I
mean, in theory, we can use the raw
here
and just use a metric name without the
selector to try and see everything.
In fact, if we do
that doesn't work.
Like that.
Yeah. We're not getting anything here.
So
how are those being exposed
in the metrics API?
Is there some
additional
mapping you need to configure?
You're asking me?
Yes. Is I'm asking you.
Is it worth killing and re redeploying the
metric service so to make sure it picks
up Prometheus?
Could I don't know. Turn off and on
again. I thought we did.
No. You killed Prometheus. You didn't kill metric
server.
But then
didn't I do a Metric server's eighty three
minutes. Upgrade the adapter.
Yeah. I'll try it. I think. Why not?
Where is our metrics there for
Oh, down.
Yeah.
Let's just we restart both of those.
Oh, we didn't add the rules. There we
go.
My fault.
Leo, your
your Prometheus package, does that handle CLI stuff
in the queue as well, or is it
just HTTP
requests?
Right now,
those metrics come from a middleware, so that
would only be HTTP requests.
I'm not entirely sure
what you would want to get from the
CLI.
Like, what what metrics we're expecting to get?
Yeah. From from a queue, I guess, you
would expect
how long each queue job took and how
often it ran.
Yeah. Adding it for the queue makes sense.
So Yeah.
Yeah.
CLI
depends whether you've got parts of your system
that
invoke the CLI, I guess. But then
yeah. Less common than other stuff.
Yeah. Queue support would make sense.
Alright. You
can put middleware on that as well, can't
you?
Can you?
Pretty sure that this middleware for
queues, because you can there's the queue, like,
facade thing has a before and after, which
you can hook into.
So Yeah. I know I know you can
hook into it. So yeah. Maybe I'll put
that on the feature list
after I fix the bug of Put that
after fixing. Yeah.
So what are these bold things for you
to put in then, David? Sorry. Yeah. I
forgot a step. So when you configure the
custom metrics, it doesn't actually consume all of
your metrics within Prometheus. What you actually have
to do is tell it which metrics to
pull out Prometheus and then to expose them
in a way that can be used in
auto scaling. So what we're actually saying is
the series queries that we want to use,
Let's just pull out all of the HTTP
request total.
Probably don't even need that. I probably get
away with just that.
We can take off this and then we
make this available as a name.
So we're just gonna say that we want
to work this out as a rate per
second. So we do a sum and a
rate over the series, etcetera.
Right. So if you had, for example, request
per second,
request total,
a few other things you'd need to expose
multiple different series queries.
Well, yeah. You would just put in your
Prometheus. You can match on the labels. I
mean, we could
I don't know if we have these labels
Kubernetes namespace.
But we can just see. Yeah, we do.
Okay. Namespace
and pod name. So, those are available. We
can query on that. That means that the
metrics server will pass in.
And then we actually don't want to query
on the request total.
That's actually saying that we want to use
that value, but what we actually want to
do is
calculate the rate of change over a two
minute interval. So, we're gonna calculate how many
requests are made every two minutes
and then sum them together across the label
matchers, and that gives us a total value
of how many requests we get every two
minutes, which means we can say if we
get more than 10 requests in a two
minute period, we wanna scale it or we
can do a thousand requests in a two
minute period. And that's actually gonna work out
really well because we can control those number
of requests, so we can we can actually
force that scale up on that. That makes
sense?
Yeah.
That metric that metric's query, is that a
Prometheus,
like, query language, I think, that's So
this here is a Prometheus query. So it
might still put forward in.
Let me just show you in the Prometheus
side of things. I think that'll help, hopefully,
cement it. So
although we don't really have requests coming in,
so let me get one
more tab. Let me get some requests coming
in with siege again.
Okay. So
we can use HTTP request total. We had
go, and then this tells us the request
that we have.
We can see we actually have multiple series
here. Why is that?
Different routes.
Yes. Okay. Thank you. And one's on post
and one is on slash. So what we
can say here is okay.
We actually want,
you know, this is gonna claim what we
have 41
and it's finished, hasn't it?
So we got 21, 40 one,
50 five. So that's gonna continue to claim,
but that's not what we want to scale
on. Like, we don't actually care about the
big number. We scale about the value over
time.
So we can do a rate
like so.
Oh,
what did I get? Oh, it might be
worth mentioning actually. The numbers that you're mentioning
go, like, the 55 and stuff. I think
our faces are covering because there's no visit
on the stream. Are they?
Oh, yeah.
Just to throw that curveball at you. Sorry.
Oh,
I'm doing it right now. Okay. Let's go
back to the start. So request total
gives me how many requests were made on
each endpoint and we can see the 61
there. I couldn't
put this off for a minute.
On.
Bye bye. Bye bye. Okay.
That's better anyway. I'm sure everyone will agree.
So
this is just the request total on each
endpoint. We can see we have 21 requests
on the homepage, 61 requests on posts. Now
because that is a
eternally incrementing number, at least for the lifetime
of a pod,
is that you don't want to scale on
61 or you don't want to scale on
7,000 or 80,000.
What we actually care about is the change
across the interval.
So that's where the rate function comes in,
where we can say, okay, let's work out
the rate of change on a five. We
don't have a scrape at the full five
of 30 seconds.
We can see zero. Well, that's right. We're
actually probably not pulling in any metrics right
now. So
let's do 200 requests.
And hopefully if we get this enough time
for it to first scrape multiple intervals, which
is ten seconds or twenty seconds, then we
should
be able see a rate of change over
thirty seconds as a positive value. There we
go.
So we can see that we had 1.4
revive requests every thirty seconds. Now it's a
four requests every thirty seconds and that will
probably continue to change for as long as
that siege command runs.
Because we have multiple endpoints, multiple pods, etcetera,
we can also wrap that in a sum
to get a single value, which tells us
the number of requests across
the thirty second
window.
And we get to say that that triggers
enough,
enough anything to scale.
Does that all make sense? Yeah.
That does make sense. Yeah.
Sure. Now, of course, we're using request tool
right now because the buckets don't quite
add up to what we want. Let's see
what we've got.
You know, we probably could get away with
using that. We can talk about that in
a second though.
But right now we can say, right, we
know if we send 200 requests to this,
we're gonna hit roughly five
before it starts dropping down. So we can
actually say, well, if we get more than
two requests on a thirty second interval, that
is enough for us to want to be
able to scale the number of pods up.
Cool.
Okay. So
we're
happy with this. We've seen this clearly run
on the Prometheus side.
Now what we can do is apply the,
redeploy the metrics adapter
with that value that has our custom rule.
We should be able to query that using
the raw API again.
It says
hoping
and we do do a rename on this
actually. So
what do we rename it to?
Request per second.
Yeah.
Issue to be request per second.
Request per second.
You
hit me so much computer.
JQ grep dash I
HTTP.
It is there. Okay.
What did I get wrong? Was this just
not there yet?
Too impatient. Okay.
So now we have
best custom metric available
for the HPA to use.
The last step.
Not that easy scaling horizontally in Kubernetes, is
it?
That will lead me into something I'd like
to talk about next and we'll maybe do
an episode on that down the line, but
for now it's okay. And that's the project.
This simplifies
scaling by adding more custom resources that you
can use, but that's
not for now. Okay.
So now we look at our HPA. We
have this value and no we don't. We
have HTTP requests per second
and
we know we can definitely trigger a five.
So I'm gonna say if we had a
three,
we'll
say 2.5
is good. So if it goes above that,
it should trigger a scaling event. And when
it falls below that, it should scale it
back down. Does that make sense as well?
Yeah.
Is there some kind of, like, cool down
period where,
like, it doesn't
so if it's hovering around 2.52
to three, it won't just, like, create, delete,
create, delete, create, delete, or does it just
do that and it's fine?
Yes.
There is ways to configure that. So what's
the best way to check that? Because I
can never remember.
But I do have all If memory
that is configured on the cluster level. Right?
I
don't think
like, if you run-in a
public cloud,
you I don't think you have access to
change that. There are defaults for it, which
is, like,
three minutes to scroll down or something. I
don't remember the numbers off the top of
my head.
Yeah. Do well, just to prevent people from
hammering their systems, I guess.
I was hoping cube control explain would show
me it, but it only has the standard
spec and not the custom spec. Oh, that's
because that's all scaling v one.
V2 beta one. Okay.
Auto scaling V2 beta one. Is that gonna
work? I have no idea.
There must be a way to provide dev
API version. Okay. So if we specify the
version on the right one,
what we want is auto scaling b
two beta one.
We can now see that we have this.
I I don't know. Maybe that isn't configurable
then.
I assume it's not very much of an
issue because Kubernetes handles the scaling side of
it for you anyway. So
Yeah. It's definitely something that that KADA offers.
I thought you could do it through custom
metrics, but I guess I'm wrong. Anyway,
let's let's let's see at scale. Right? That's
why we're here. So
we have a single Laravel thingy running here.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna just
pop open
some new split
so that we can run a watch command.
I recently changed this alias from g h,
which I know and understand to g h
b because I wanna use the g h
c l I, which is g h. I
know that's completely irrelevant, but it's been frustrating
the hell at me all week. Okay. And
it's only Tuesday.
Okay.
So
we can continue to scrape. I
reapplied you. Is that old? Old or new?
I think they're old.
Age, twelve minutes, three minutes. Yeah. Hopefully, those
are just
old. That's not even the name of the
metric I use anymore. So
for a second. Yeah, I think we're good.
So we can tell you to describe that.
We should see the scale and events happen.
Now what we wanna do is run siege
again.
And we also want I'm gonna do one
more split
as we wanna track the pods as they
change over time. So we're on a watch
on that. We're gonna run siege here and
I'm going to describe this every couple of
seconds and see if we can see the
scaling in real time.
Assuming I've not fucked any of that up.
By the way, the default downscale
window is five minutes. It's in the documentation
about
horizontal port auto scaling under support for cool
down and delay.
It's an argument you it's a flag on
the cube controller manager, so you do need
to have control plane access to change that.
And you can only specify the duration of
what they call the downscale stabilization
time window.
So I think upscaling is instant, but it
will wait five minutes before scaling down.
Okay. Yeah. That makes sense.
So it's it's, the public cloud, like,
manager will be what handles that unless you
roll your own Kubernetes clusters.
Yeah. I
am not entirely sure off the top of
my head. Some providers might allow you to
pass arguments
to the different
control plane components,
and that would be how you'd configure it
in that case.
Yeah. But that's per provider, so it's down
to who we use, I guess.
Okay. Fair enough. But I assume that whoever
you use will have whatever they consider reasonable
defaults, so it should be fine.
Okay.
I think our c is finished before we
try and use trigger that. I'm running it
again. We can see
we're about 17
here now.
We oh, good time in there. We have
a week.
As soon as I ran that describe, we
got a rescale event based on our
that value going above the 2.5 that we
are trying to hit. We can see that
it's worked out that we probably won another
four.
Unlucky
for it, it's gonna continue to keep scaling
up, but still, it's added four new instances.
And if we run and get pods, we'll
see
we now have all the Laravels run. Oh,
wait. That's the completed ones. All the Laravel
projects running. I'm gonna quit siege.
We'll run a watch on this again and
we should see within about a minute or
two. Well, it's gonna be five minutes based
on what you just told us.
That'll scale then. So you've got five minutes
of dead air to fill. Go.
Now the first thing I wanna say there
is it's five minutes by default. We are
now assuming that Docker desktop actually relies on
that default.
I have no idea. We we will we
will find out if it's five minutes.
Well, we're gonna finish up. I can't believe
that has been an hour and a half
almost already. That has So, Benko, what's that
doing there now that started new ones, has
it? Well, the value, I think, on aggregate
over time is still above the 2.5.
It's just fallen, but you'll probably find it's
actually scaling more up.
And if we describe the HPA,
it has done another rescale. Oh, no. That's
the first rescale. I think maybe some pods
just died.
I saw that we're terminating there. Yeah.
Then we get pods, grab, Laravel.
Yeah. We still got the five. It just
looks like we
lost a few for whatever reason.
Oh, I know why that's gonna be. The
probes on it are gonna be failing because
we've not got any metrics, probably. It's probably
given a client error or something.
Oh, because there's no actual requests hitting anymore.
Yeah. Maybe. I mean, that's complete speculation at
this point in time, but it's possible.
Alright. I mean, I think we've
we've shown everything we want to show. I
think it's great that Leo has, you know,
packed up this project and providing people with
a working almost.
It
will be working. I I'm debugging it.
I'm I'm not gonna delay the stream with
the debugging.
Instead, I'll just make it work, and then,
you know, by the time someone rewatches this
in a week, it's just magically gonna work
when they pull the latest tag.
Yeah. No. I think you're doing great work.
I'm really glad to see that there's Prometheus
auto wiring super Laravel component that has exposed
in the metrics that we need. And I
think it's it's still enough there. You can
still calculate the number of requests over a
given interval and scale just as we have
done today.
And, of course, I would actually like to
monitor and keep my plus five plus infinity
below
10% or whatever, but
that could be something we do in the
future. Maybe I can help contribute to the
library that you're working on too.
Then we got the metrics, we hooked up
Prometheus, we added the annotations to the deployment,
we scraped the metrics, we deployed the metrics
server, we deployed the metrics, the Prometheus adapter,
and we deployed
the rules that expose the custom metric, configure
in the HPA,
and that's all it took to get all
scaling on Kubernetes for
Yeah. You you make it sound so easy.
I
think it would be awesome to take a
look at the Keter project and then a
future stream. If you both wanna join me
for that,
it's not something I'm overly familiar with. I've
used it. I like that. I haven't got
it in production, but maybe a little bit
of an exploration episode where we see if
we can simplify this at all and take
another look at the configure of the buckets
and stuff. I think there's a lot more
we can do here to make this easier
for people, so I'm excited to to do
that in future episodes.
And for that. Sounds good. Awesome. Well, thank
you both for joining me today, working through
that. I hope the people watching got something
of value from at this time. I know
last week was very frustrating for the people
that watched two hours only to be like,
what the fuck was that?
Hopefully, it was fixed at this time, and
that library was very helpful. Is there anything
either of you would like to say before
we wrap up for today?
The library will work correctly eventually.
That's all I have to say.
And it's open source, accepting contributions.
Go check it out. Try it out. Let's
help, Leo, by working out where the cracks
are and failing issues.
Accepting pull requests.
Alright. You too have a great day. I'll
speak to you both soon, and thanks everyone
for watching. I'll see you later.
Thanks. Bye. Thanks a lot. See you.